the old man hangs on that's the focus of
tonight's
angle yeah the other cable networks were
going wall toall with war coverage today
but the focus wasn't Israel's war
against Hamas it was a hacked
prosecutors war against Trump and the
courts this case has made him angrier
than almost any other case I'm really
flabbergasted right now I've never seen
anything like this and all of my time of
being a lawyer let Trump hang himself
essentially in this trial now more on
the legal angle later but the reason
they devoted what8 n hours of coverage
to the trial has less to do with its
merits than with the recent polls that
show Trump trouncing Biden in five key
Battleground States Arizona Georgia
Michigan Nevada and Pennsylvania
according to the New York Times Trump
has eaten significantly into Biden's
advantages among younger Black and
Hispanic voters many of whom retain
positive views of the policies Trump
enacted wow well it turns out that
Biden's getting America Tangled Up in
more Wars while driving down real median
income isn't so popular after all and
even with his significant lead in key
States Mr Trump appears to have room to
grow as voters say they're open to
supporting the former president than
they are to backing Mr Biden which large
with large shares of Voters saying they
trust Mr Trump on the economy and
National Security now no wonder the
Democrat Dam of support for Biden seemed
to to be buckling over the weekend if
they weren't pushing Biden to step aside
it was a gentle nudge and not so subtle
warnings there's just a lot of concern
about the age issue and uh and that is
something that I think he needs to uh
Ponder just do a check and say is this
the right thing uh to do time is
fleeting here and this is probably the
last moment uh for him to do that check
and it's it's it's probably good if he
does
okay yeah David because we all know that
Joe Biden has always put country first
never put his financial interest of his
family ahead of His official duties
that's never happened then there was
political statistician Nate Silver's
tweet saying you have the whole
electorate basically screaming Biden's
too old there's a year worth of campaign
to go very likely some reversion to the
fundamentals Trump's legal issues
probably larger liability than seem now
but still Democrats can't say they
weren't
warned they desperately want Biden to
become someone he never was and at 80
never can be somehow Biden has to find a
way to animate um the excitement
enthusiasm that I think he he tapped as
a as a man of the center a man who put
the country back together quickly he's
got he's got to do it soon and and
reverse these perceptions um uh
otherwise we're really heading toward
what I fear will be cataclysmic election
uh next
year yeah for the typical DC and
Manhattan Elites who never bother
considering what life really is like for
middleclass voters they're confounded
that people don't love persistent
inflation Sky High food and gas prices
and mortgage interest payments that
Crush first-time home buyers they're
shocked that that's
unpopular the once reasonable Jonathan
Carl is worried when you hear the word
anybody remember he's actually refering
to the regime media types like himself
look this is a wakeup call this is
frightening for not just the Biden White
House not just for Democrats but for
anybody who fears what a return to a
trump presidency would mean he can win
now listen to the language fears and
frightening he would never cover a a you
know a poll favorable to Biden from the
Republican perspective because you can
bet that a lot of regular folks are
terrified of the prospect of Biden
staggering through another four more
years including African-Americans such
as Karen Wright a business consultant
McDona Georgia who immigrated to the
United States from Jamaica in 1982 and
she told the New York Times that she had
always voted for Democrats seeing them
as the best option for younger
immigrants particularly those from
predominantly black countries like hers
now though she believes Biden hasn't
followed through on his campaign
promises on immigration and worries that
Democrats have gone too far in their
Embrace of lgbtq issues next year M
Wright said that she planned to support
Republicans up and down the ballot and
that she was not alone that's
devastating no wonder Bill Crystal's
panties are in a bunch posting on X it's
time President Biden has served our
country well I'm confident he'll do so
for the next year but it's time for an
active personal sacrifice and public
spirit it's time to pass the torch the
Next Generation it's time for Biden to
announce he won't run in 2024 pass the
torch can't carry a torch on what planet
does Bill Crystal live now I got to say
this though Biden may not understand
what's really happening around the world
not well at least but he is with it
enough to know that all things
considered being president helps Hunter
and the Gang more than if he were not
president and enriching his family and
protecting them are all that ever
mattered to
Biden now there's no denying that
Democrats and the
want him out but if that's what they
want they're going to have to do a heck
of a lot more than hint and nudge
they're going to have to use leverage on
the only thing that Joe Biden really
cares about his family hard to see them
doing that but look anything can happen
but Democrats are in a jam of their own
making they failed across the board and
they deserve to lose across the board
they failed in their pledges even to
strengthen democracy remember that
pledge since now fewer Americans trust
our system of government with Biden at
the helm 76% I almost fell over saying
this of those pulled now say that we're
heading in the wrong direction only in
the liberal mind would that Democrat
track record actually be called a
success definitely reelect that and why
would anyone in his right mind think
Gavin Newsome with his horror track
record in California can do any better
than Biden what on Earth does he have to
offer we'd go from president sniffy to
president smart me no thank you and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else